I think I know why is as good as you be
is you what is so special about Gemini
man is at the center of it you have two
characters played by one person across
generations you're looking at will he's
looking at his younger self that's a
phenomenal experience for an audience I
play both 50 year old Henry and 23 year
old junior who's Santu killer
being chased by himself that's a really
compelling idea for a story thanks to
the technology no it's possible
creating a digital human is one of the
hardest things you can do in visual
effects this is not d aging this does
not face replacement what you see it for
jr. is a completely digital creation
100% driven by Wilson is performance
captured his performance is his emotion
it's his ability as an actor to create
this really rich performance and then
play off of himself
I couldn't have played junior at 23
years old but now I'm able to understand
and capture both characters because of
the amount of experience that I've had
as an actor the technology were
inventing is something Angers been
wanting to do for a long time he's
making a leap forward and no other
director has even tried to do when you
see the two Will Smith well that's
something we never experienced before
this technology is going to change how
movies are made and how movies are seen
[Music]
you
you